I am so excited to talk to you about many things.
I wanna first start off
with you released your first holiday album.
I couldn't believe it was your first and your son is on it.
Will you please tell me
about what making that album was like
and what the experience was?
And thank you for putting it out into the world.
Well, it was always a bucket list thing
that I have always wanted to do.
There's just so much about,
you know, touring and making albums
and timing stuff that it's sometimes hard
to just do everything you wanna do all at once.
So you have to figure it out.
I knew at the end of 2019
that, you know this was kind of the,
that was the next step I wanted to take
and started working on the Christmas album.
And it was just such a joy for me
especially throughout 2020,
to be able to work on such positive music
and getting to sing Christmas.
You can't be upset, you know,
in the time that you're just singing Christmas songs.
So it was such a nice stress reliever
for me to be able to go into the studio
and sing these songs and "Little Drummer Boy"
is one of my favorite Christmas songs ever.
And as I was recording it, I could just hear my son's
little perfect five-year-old voice singing these words.
'Cause that's just his personality, he's a giver,
he wants to make things for you and give things to you
and he likes to write songs.
He'll just, "Here's the song I made up".
So I asked him if he might wanna come in and sing with me
and he was super excited and did such a great job.
Now, when you hear his voice,
'cause I don't know if singing is hereditary,
if it is, there's no one in my family that's a singer,
we're all actors.
How do you know?
Like, or just was it like this was just fun
and you wanted to do it?
Well, it was just fun and I wanted to do it,
but I also, you know you can kind of tell
when someone has pitch.
He can sing along with me
and you can tell what song he's singing
if he's just singing on his own
because he's singing the correct notes.
I mean, he's almost six
but he is just, you know, a little guy.
So I don't know if he'll have that
or have that passion at all.
We're supportive of whatever he wants to do,
but he definitely has pitch.
So I figured him coming in and singing.
We could make it to where, you know use the best parts
of whatever he did and make it good.
But honestly, most of it was from one take,
which is impressive.
Is that now one of those memories that just lives on?
Yes, I mean, I've told everybody,
I was like, I don't know how cooperative he's gonna be,
I don't know if he's gonna (indistinct) go once and be like
I don't wanna do this anymore,
but if nothing else I have this moment,
I have this day he got to come to work with me
and see what I do.
And it was such a magical experience in the studio.
But then having that moment
ingrained forever in a musical form, his little voice.
He already pronounces his rums.
Like, just from that point to this point,
he doesn't say pauampompompom anymore.
He says, Parapampampam.
And it's like that was such a fleeting moment,
it's not there anymore
and I have that forever.
It's so true.
Like my kids, if they come visit me at work
I don't know what version of them I'm getting that day.
And sometimes they'll come on and just be into it
and cute and charming and wanna participate,
some days, you know, they're not in that mood.
It's exciting when they're in your world,
you can enjoy it, things are flowing.
It's like, these are these moments I cherish so much.
Can't get them back, that's for sure.
That sounds just like my favorite line
in "Planes, Trains and Automobiles"
He's missing his daughter's play
and John Candy looks at him, he goes,
"Yeah, those moments don't come around again."
(laughing)
Okay, I have to ask you about organization.
I hear you're a fan of organization
and it wasn't my forte growing up,
I was like pig pen and I lost everything
and I was just Bohemian and whimsical
and now I'm really trying to be a different person.
What are your tips for organizing?
What is Carrie Underwood's tips for organizing?
I mean, I feel like it's important to focus on one thing.
I feel like if I walk into my kitchen,
my kitchen is overwhelming.
If I just walk into my pantry
and like that is what I'm taking charge of,
that is what I'm organizing.
I feel like that is, it is doable.
It is one space, work on one space, one drawer,
one little area.
Don't just go in because then you feel
like you haven't done anything.
You could work all day
and if you're just Willy nilly, putting stuff away
you feel like you haven't really gotten any accomplished.
You don't see it in front of you.
If you work on one drawer, one pantry, one thing
then that's doable.
And then sometimes I feel like taking things out,
like taking all of it out
and putting it back in the way it should go
is helpful instead of just moving things around.
And while you're doing that, you can throw things away.
You gotta be brutal, let it go.
If you're not gonna use it, if it doesn't serve your purpose
if you're not gonna eat it,
if you're not gonna like whatever.
You have worn it in you know, a year, like just let it go.
My therapist (indistinct),
because I have a time management thing
I'm trying to conquer.
He was like, you need to be ruthless on yourself.
And that's a word that's really stuck with me
and haunted me.
Because you feel
so much lighter afterwards
when you get rid of, when you purge
and then all the things that you need
are right in front of you,
you can breathe, it just feels better.
There's someone who said this saying,
"Your head is as messy as your room is."
And it just was the light bulb
and I heard you even like make your bed every morning.
Yeah, I mean, that's, if I don't have time,
I don't have time.
But when I walk by my room, if I'm there in my house
and I walk by my room and my bed is in shambles,
I'm like, it just irks me every time I walk by it.
So at some point I have to stop and I have to make it.
And then each time I walk by, I feel good.
Well, it's funny, 'cause I read
that you like to make your bed
and when the person said
"your head is as messy as your room is",
a starting place for me was the bed.
And it became symbolic of like, I start the day this way
that intention might carry me through other areas.
Well, and it's the kind of thing that it's like,
okay, does this take me that long to do?
No, like just do it and get it over with,
and then get on with your life.
And that's how I look at, you know, working out
and taking care of myself too.
Just get it done, get up, go to the gym,
then you've done it, it's over.
You feel better, you're doing something good for yourself.
And you think about, it's just making your bed,
but it makes you feel better and then you've done it,
you check it off the list and you move on
and get onto more important things.
And you have that foundation
of I have already done something today.
(upbeat music)